look at you look at
you look great
you're the only person who looks sane
out of all of us
what's up bro do you came by yourself
budget cuts bro curling king by myself
budget cuts
can i sit here no
you can't sit here dude you could don't
this is so weird
have you what are you doing dude
yo do you make this place clean yeah
everyone has an antibiotic oh my gosh
those are fresh though
you see me you can't dude you came solo
yeah it came so well
no you usually come with the entourage
cove cove would hit the
hit the bank did the bankroll not yet
get tore
can't tv can't nothing
we're rolling out let me just rush real
quick you guys want to start getting
started
good to see you brother you already got
you see you see
where you see the guns i'm not mad at
him dude
[Laughter]
we ready chin hold on let me just pop in
there
i don't know why you [ __ ]
didn't wipe this we didn't know there's
a cleaning team that comes in oh they
already there's a green thing that comes
out at night no if you did if you didn't
know there's a clean team that comes
where does this need to be let me do it
for you no no
and i got it i'm already touching it
he's fine
thank you i love that you wore those
kicks
well i know you like the you know you
like the flex i don't have those
you know these are these little ones
those are my favorite scott claps the
ones i
have every other one he has i don't have
those why don't you get them i know i
need to i'm gonna get them now how many
pairs of kicks you have
probably two hundo like legit way too
many it's too many
way too many they keep dropping dope
collabs and then you think you need them
it's so sick right it's it's a yeah it's
not good 37
it's like sometimes like and where are
you going are you going to the game
you're not going to the game you can't
wear them on stage but you know stage
time really
right there's nothing you can do with it
yeah i was supposed to do
uh cap city in austin end of this month
then i just got word from their
management that they're not
they can't put on shows because at first
they were like alright capacity is gonna
be half i went that's fine i just need
the stage time i'll come up and my crew
will have fun
and then a week later they go bad news
i'm pretty sure this is out there bad
news we're shutting down forever
cap city where is that austin
like a statement i never played that
dude a staple of like
one of the best clubs ever shutting down
for good
if if you're rogan it's good right
because think about opening up a club
out there so might as well take that
[ __ ] over
damn that's the bomber dog isn't it a
bummer like the mom and pop
shops it's just a i don't even know the
club you would love it i know but it's
just a [ __ ]
it bumped out right and like wise guys
in salt lake city
keith have you ever done one no i
haven't i was gonna do so
i had your crush on wise guys yeah
that's a great room and denver i was
going to do
comedy works yeah the whatever the one
out there
have you done anything different because
i had to get past endeavor in order to
do a full hour there
no i had it booked sometime in the
spring
i mean you're a vet though but you've
done stand-up for a while like you
started and they stopped and
yeah so super famous kind of and then
are we rolling yeah we're [ __ ]
rolling dude
yeah because comedy they would i think
wendy she wouldn't at first she's like
i'm good and they would they wouldn't
let me you like go there that's my
hometown that's the club you want to do
so you haven't done it i have oh i've
done it four times i had to get past
though
what do you mean passed like that she
had to see a set and then go okay
but you've done it i've done it four
times since but at first there was but
what have you done recently like what's
your next
so it's supposed to be cap city have you
done one of these car gigs
no i have off i have offers but and
you've talked to brooke chrysler he's
like he's the best thing ever
but then if i talk to anybody but birth
like don't do them dude
and then uh gary owen was in here he's
like dude you knew tommy t's
it's in uh oakland and the audience like
they do it outside in the parking lot
they sell like 150 170 tickets he did
like 12 shows
and the audience has headphones on i'd
rather do that than a parking lot
have you done any dates i have i've done
one little
thing last week in la and las cienega at
this spot i mean it was literally like
40 people it was it would be the
equivalent of doing an open mind
but it was good to do it like it was
dope the people were
spread out and you know i mean it was
fun to do it like i was hi
how clunky were you though i was taking
six months off
all kinds of clunky because also i would
i was just
you know like when they give you the mic
yeah you know and like
and there you go that and then and um
just you know like getting a sense of
what was going on
you know and it was just it was but it
was i was
hyped to do it and was there any what
other comics were
on there burr neil brennan oh monsters
um you know but it was literally like if
you didn't know anybody you'd be like
this is some
la open mic yeah but i was like yo this
i was pumped to do this [ __ ] because you
haven't done it in
six six [ __ ] months man i was loved
out about austin
they literally just yesterday canceled
but then i'm doing dallas first week of
october
okay we're at addison improv have you
done addison
there's a hyenas there and there's
addison what is it
like what's the rules i think it seats
like 350 i think they're doing 200.
now you have that scarf on it doubles as
a mass but you
you like this very fast i know you're
such a [ __ ]
you're like a [ __ ] like you're like
you're like one person that
like if there wasn't covert or covert
was officially dead tomorrow
you'd still rock it because you'd be
like well just in case
exactly but you're like that's a fashion
it's a billy the king
now you can't say [ __ ] what are you
gonna do no you can't
do whatever you want you can't do
anything and you can do [ __ ] dumb as
[ __ ]
as long as you got this on because you
wanted to wear that before
corona but you just never had the ball
give me excuses like the
the thing like the tie i match it with
the fit
what's up dog it's an accessory now you
came in the travis scott
yeah goddamn it's because i know you
like to drip on them so i was like
because you you know i usually just rock
my new balances but i i [ __ ] with my
jewelry
but but i was like let me just let me
just let me just
there's like a little like a stiff jab
to your face it's like an older brother
movie like
boom like oh just like we both got
trapped scots on
those are i have those too do you really
i got those two are you becoming a
sneaker head those are those are
[ __ ] good to see you man isn't it
weird like during i love you man i love
you i miss you dude
i miss so many people man i miss the
people that i don't want to see
like me too when i start missing running
into my ex-wife
yeah then i know that things are bad
because i never want to [ __ ] see her
ever i never [ __ ] want to see her so
like when i'm like oh you know like
i can't even [ __ ] see her [ __ ] ass
you know is this a bit do you do this
[ __ ]
no but i i just you know that's why i
came here to workshop yeah yeah
that works up yeah but isn't it weird
because like that there's no more like
you don't see anybody
so one time i see people are really when
when i do when i do this podcast
right so it's like it's a [ __ ] bummer
like we saw bert the other day chris
sure
gary owen just yeah like [ __ ] dude yeah
you're griffin like this is the hang of
it
yes it's the hangman i i i like i said
you know we're saying i don't know if
we're doing on camera now but like the
the the gigs in town are the thing i
miss the most because
on the road is is a different thing it's
like it's a different energy that you
give like you know like the the
the local [ __ ] when you're doing 15
minutes and
10 minutes and 20 minutes local shit's
an away game yeah no
like you might have some fans there
maybe yeah yeah yeah when you're just
popping up like it's an away game that's
true when you're on the road like it's a
home
people came to see the home game yeah so
you're pretty you're pretty comfortable
yeah so it's messed up it's not the end
of the world right you know right you
mess up at the store
the improv and you're following some
monsters like get the [ __ ] especially
the comedy store
the monsters yeah it's it's a [ __ ]
it's a it's a high-pressure thing so are
you moving
out of los angeles so who's moved out of
los angeles um
well so rogan i think joey diaz was the
first he
joey is like jersey he's in jersey he
left he's
gone gone left i think two weeks ago
rogan left a week ago
he's full full-on in austin he's family
and everything
uh brian and chris might as well be gone
[Laughter]
goals like that's one is my things in
life i put in like the top thing
top ten things i love it when you do it
but it's pounding that ass
yeah but the they don't say pounding
that ass but the one with him
yeah sure but the one thing too is like
we can talk basketball not get
interrupted like oh do those guys sweat
right like [ __ ] have you been watching
the games i haven't missed the game
it's been like sports have been my
savior during this cobra
stink [ __ ] god when when they when
they
uh ride it or uh uh decide not to play
that one
for that two days dude i was like cause
you get so used to it
oh no no no no no no no no come on
anyone there's a better way to do this
and and you and like there's it's such a
break from your [ __ ]
i have something to look forward to
something to look forward to the games
have been
so good it's the best basketball we've
had in a long time guys aren't traveling
the teams are healthy for the most part
they're all healthy everyone's healthy i
mean well giannis got babies got hurt
but but for you know what i'm saying
like everyone's pretty healthy dude and
the aesthetic
of it is not bad like i don't know it's
like playing in there for them
like the guys like if they hear that but
when you're watching the game because
it's like the size of the court
you know with the fake fans and the
sound you forget that there's no one in
there they knocked it out of the park
with it then bae's done it the best
killed no covert test no positive tests
none nothing in the bubble uh um
apparently
you know the bubble they got everything
in there you could get it's like
anything you want and i'm like
they're like they want to leave them
like you guys you don't know you're not
missing anything out here no like your
favorite restaurant shut down you're not
getting the sushi
what they meant what they can't have is
you know they're young guys with
fame and money they can't have the
instagram thoughts they can't have that
snapper they can't have the snap
yeah but you could you now they're
allowed to bring one or two and you got
to go to your top tier
you gotta you gotta you gotta it's like
my space stays you gotta you have five
yeah and you gotta do top two and and i
think it's top one
it's maybe top two like something you
know what's the [ __ ] williams is on that
he's obviously that's my guy
sweet little one williams of los angeles
clippers he's
on that um that polygamy yes he's i mean
not officially but he's
about that light he's down like he's got
girlfriends and they're they're like
he's got like a little like
friends and then they're friends so he
might have two girls in there and it's
like a known thing you know what's
[ __ ] up
is so the players uh can see their
families and the families can be in the
bubble the coaches can
i don't understand the denver nuggets go
shut to the [ __ ] nuggets they're not
gonna get past this round but whatever
that's my squad but they're good they're
good they're really good
murray djokovic come on man murray's a
[ __ ] yeah how great of a draft
pick
they're good they're [ __ ] that jamal
i mean they're just you know what they
are they're not tough
no they don't have that killer instinct
like not yet like a butler or
murray's getting there though he's
getting there i mean they're hitting
donovan in the last series
but but 50 40 50 both of them they're
just the clippers have too much d
for i mean it ain't over but i would be
surprised if the clippers didn't
close that out in six there's nobody on
the planet like you so why would you
sleep on a generic mattress built for
everybody
for everybody's body maybe you're not
sleeping well here is the problem man
you're sleeping on that basic matrix
you guys need to get helix sleep helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes
you complete the quiz it matches your
body type to the perfect mattress
just for you not anybody else it's
unique
just to you side sleeper hot sleeper
plush bed firm bed we got you covered
man
helix sleep was even awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick
of 2019 and 220 by gq and wired magazine
in my house the only mattress i have is
helix sleep
i have people freaking trying to break
in my house to sleep on the mattresses
non-stop
my mother-in-law father-in-law uncles
aunts nieces
cousins everybody trying to sleep at my
house and i figured out it's because my
helix mattress they're so damn
comfortable
just go to helixsleep.com take their
two-minute sleep quiz
the match you to customize matches that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk free
they even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will so don't
worry about it
helix sleep is offering you guys up to
200 off all mattresses and free pillows
for the final kid listeners helix
sleep.com
fighter that's helixsleep.com fighter
for up to two hundred dollars off
helixleep.com fighter i i thought if
anyone was gonna
dominate in the bubble and because
there's no home game there's no
traveling and all he does is sleep eat
and
[ __ ] drink basketball be quiet
leonard and he's all right
like he's not bawling like these other
guys 36 a game third
he's so understated though his game is
so
even at his best there's no highlights
there's no dunks
there's no crossovers he's hitting those
mid-range jumps that's it but
you know so he's going off though yeah
and then he'll have 32 there's no
like [ __ ] you know making it to
[ __ ] ball is life
you know top 10 there's never anything
with new balance is on
he's got a new bounce it was a bad move
but he's probably getting so much money
it's perfect sense for him to be on new
balance 100 yeah
because it's it's him and and but like
kawhi leonard like you'll like look up
they have 34 points you know nine
rebounds
eight assists and you're like damn and
there's no highlights no there's nothing
they never show anything
with like except for the block it gets
worried though but that's not even a
[ __ ] highlight it was just because
somebody saw that it was one figure
i don't know i mean but they're they're
so deep so like
nobody's gonna beat the clippers when
like if paul george shows
paul george is the key to them winning
because if is going to get his
and then the bench with lou williams
who's six man of the year and montreal
is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] so if if paul george shows
up yeah
i don't think i'm not worried about him
showing up he had that little law he
said he got a little [ __ ] up in the
bubble
you know he had to uh disengage comments
on his social media on instagram
really yeah which i was like bro why are
you reading that
yeah i i i he said the bubble [ __ ] him
up he had a little a little a little
bubble
i get it i get it you know not having
your not being able to go where you want
for that period of time even though they
have everything there
can can bug you out you know what i mean
like i want to get in like i don't want
to be here so when i
am finished with this i can leave you
know yeah you feel good yeah so it's
like it's not like you can't leave
they can't leave so but paul's a
[ __ ] but also it's like dude
just
just stick it out to october man and
you're gonna be what i'm saying there's
there
you're entitled to like yo where cuz i
mean think about it you've had to have
days
where like i i like saturday i was just
like [ __ ] this
it was so [ __ ] hot it's like [ __ ]
this goddamn [ __ ] la
these [ __ ] fires the goddamn corona
the goddamn
i've got two places you know it gets to
you every morning
listen man you know continue on to find
the kid without brian kellen
what people don't realize brian's my
brother like that's my [ __ ] guy man
so it's like not be able to do the show
without him for me is a struggle
like i love you right the rhythm and
it's just but it's like i
mean him would see each other every week
multiple times for seven years
right i haven't seen brian and i don't
know how and that's not
by my choice that's brian's choice he
was like you need to continue
doing it and until i figure my thing out
i'm
i don't want to bring down the show
right lose all advertising right right
right so
carry the ship until we figure it out
right i didn't want to i could be honest
i
i didn't want to do it i was like a lot
if you're not if if i just have to
figure this show out which is an
entirely new show by myself
i'm i'm busy man i got this [ __ ] going
on over here right but
me and him thought it was best to do
this until he can come back right now
you know i don't talk about it but it
[ __ ] it sucks dude it sucks not
having brian everybody does
it's called the fighter and the kid i
mean you you you if you did a different
show it would be called something in
something or
you know i know or just like the the the
big dumb
[ __ ] podcast exactly if you if we have
that's on below the bell and
no but it could be cool the biggest in
the world but can we just say but yeah
i'm doing if you ditch one to do a
double one like uh this is brendan
chavez welcome to the big dumb
[ __ ] podcast welcome you can do big dumb
[ __ ]
i'm just saying i'm throwing that out
there it's not a bad idea
i don't have any more shows to do
because i understand it but but you
should be going
like i say if you include food truck
diaries you can you can say
you're welcome when i give you that
because now you have a title for a big
dumb [ __ ] yeah welcome to the big dumb
[ __ ] podcast look at my ears look at my
scarf
my dude i wore the scarf for you i'm
just saying i felt comfortable i'm just
saying you're gonna cry i'm just saying
that if if you want it so
you should call your podcast the the big
cry baby covet [ __ ]
let's move on i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding let's move on now
because my podcast the i am rap report
stereo podcast
is behind the paywall right behind the
pay wall yeah and
but but killing it and and so much as a
paywall can
as much as a paywall can but you're
you're you're doing well right you just
named off your 17 podcast you should get
behind
and and just listen to the i am wrapped
portrait it's 2.99 how much did this
coffee cost you how much was this like
6.99
no it's across the street commissary so
5.99 like
four dollars okay so 299 luminary on
luminary in australia now you're
assuming i don't listen to you trevor
noah
there's never heard yeah trevor noah big
boy
so much for me he cries all he does is
cry i know you're you're
is the network called the cry babies
now you got a cough no oh no you got a
cough
[ __ ] i want you to i want you to back up
and pull some episodes where every
episode i cough in the old building
the other building oh doesn't it he's
not good for a coffer
like right now very floating in an
airport do not sneeze do not
cough if you do it's like you said the
worst racial term ever everyone looks at
you trust me and you're like no
i'm gonna coffer by nature i've been
coughing since
12 11 i'm jewish ashkenazi jew sure
we cough we snort so this is not a good
time it's kind of like a tick for you
it's not a good time for coffee because
it's not definitely it's like it's like
there's another bit there it's like
literally
like saying the word really is like
saying the n word and
yelling then word in the airport is like
that do that on the plane and
people i can't even imagine people will
[ __ ] so yeah have you flown oh yeah a
bunch
is it is it weird in on your own row
it's dope
because every time well it's either
there has to be a seat between everyone
and what they
really want is one person per row so
it's great
there's no lines at tsa you don't need i
have clear and tsa you don't
need it right you don't even need right
you could no you could if your flight's
at noon you should show my eyes
oh [ __ ] dude you're a hot mess
you're a hot mess but yeah back to the
baby get covered bro
i bet you could i can't you know what
you could get and you'd probably be fine
rap do you have any underlying health
issues
i i do i just told you i i cough well
the cough is whatever
i have i can't get it my father-in-law
has
literally he has he's had pneumonia has
the worst lungs ever he got it
and i was like oh [ __ ] it you well how
old was he
60 something he got you gave it to him
no
he got it are you a super spreader no he
got it from work are you a super
spreading [ __ ] sucker me and brian are
trying to figure out we don't know if it
was me or brian but one of us got it and
then passed it on
you're super spreaders um brian could
have been
he's not here to defend himself okay
with brian okay but um
but with the nba how about no positive
tests no one's tested positive
how about in the nfl not in a bubble in
training camp they've done 44
000 tests they've had one positive
they're doing well
yo the nfl starts off tomorrow thursday
night is this airing today or thursday
today
the nfl starts thursday patrick my
homeboy versus sean watson
i don't know if you [ __ ] guys are
ready but the nfl is happening
these two aren't i am i'm [ __ ] ready
i can't wait
i think the rating is gonna eat [ __ ]
because no one's like aware of it
because without any preseason the build
up
and you know usually the hard knock show
they'll figure something out but between
something right i mean i think that you
know this whole thing about the ratings
are like the nba ratings are down
compared to what
like when was their basketball on
[ __ ] labor day what what can
last year's like the nba ratings what is
down well compared to regular envy but
it's it's down 40
is it yeah and the ufc is higher than
it's ever been
they're powering through it ufc is
higher than serbian golf is higher than
seven
you don't think the mix in politics with
sports is i do
i think it's a huge i do think it's an
issue but i also think with the nba you
can't compare their ratings during the
[ __ ] summer bubble
to the regular nba season yeah i think
you can because more
more people are at home i guess other
sports are up like you have so ufc's up
crush it and golf crushes golf is up
crushing nascar was crushing till they
got political
because because a study came out i
forget who it is
90 of people went sports is a is a
getaway from corona
and this whole protesting all this it's
my one getaway
so when the the leagues mix it we don't
want it
let me tell you something i i get that i
don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not am i if i like baseball i'll be
watching the [ __ ] baseball i've been
peeking in on that just just
just to hear just something just to hear
it the it looks the worst
though baseball because it's that
ginormous stadium no one's
it's a bum and when that looks like a
pickup game and when the ball hits the
they're so sad when someone says to
homer and it just goes
but when about where it goes it makes
that [ __ ] tower it's a foul ball
nothing it's the worst
nba and ufc is the best by far um and
well let's stay basketball because i
want to ask you ufc said so who do you
predict now because then we have the
lakers are up
are you a laker hater are you a lebron
laker hater of course yes
you and my brother would get along so
well of course he bawled out last night
at his age he's a [ __ ]
animal and and then when he shot the
dishes
the [ __ ] that was trimming he was
punching people [ __ ] like he was playing
seventh grade his defense is ridiculous
right now the energy that he expands is
crazy he's getting rest
he's gotten all this rest he's they're
posed out of any time for him to win at
his age would be now in the bubble
that's it
because next year they're [ __ ] not
sure they're [ __ ] next year i mean
we've been saying
giannis is going to go to golden state
probably and then where everybody's
[ __ ]
that's the rumor yes everybody everybody
[ __ ] giannis goes to golden state
i'm gonna quit watching the nba we said
that when kevin durant went to golden
state he's
kevin's my favorite player okay slim
reaper come on
sick the best seven footer slim reaper
seven footer the reaper the reaper's ill
and how about he gets on uh
social media accounts how many minutes
do you have
none i'm not i don't really mess with it
at all anymore you don't have any burner
accounts
never never oh i got like i i don't you
do you're very worried about that
kevin uh kevin durant admitted i still
[ __ ] with that bird
i was like why not just do it out of
your own i do it there and then i got
that burner life
i'm how about skip bayless with the
burner life but his isn't like going at
trolls
his is he he got caught because he
thought he was out of the
his other account but he's in his
original account so he's like skip
you're the best man
i can't believe people are hating on you
you're the best analyst in the game
but he did it from his original what was
this recently probably
two years ago i'm all about that burner
account you should do a cough
like a like but but also you got to
bring it back to like my first
appearance because i was coughing
what you do no you're fine it's right
bodies so if
if you if you were um making your
prediction now so we have we have lakers
are are in it with houston they're up
2-1 the clippers
2-1 don't win that series the um
milwaukee's done
that was tough miami beat hashem i think
they got my i predicted miami would make
it to the finals
on my i am wrapping mario [ __ ] your
brother he doesn't have the idea
you and him are the same what's his name
jay you i wish he was here because you
and him could talk basketball like a
[ __ ]
but he predicted miami he's predicting
miami clippers
in the finals yeah me too here's what's
weird is i think milwaukee got
sidetracked with the whole protest thing
and all that
giannis gets hurt and then but they were
getting their ass beat
i think butler went off can we admit
butler's the secret sauce
he's a sauce because that's really that
oh we're fine with ben simmons embiid
no you're not ben simmons and joel
embiid are soft
and to be that talented and to be
like first of all joel and beat super
talented
ridiculously talented i need my big guys
to at least
to be able to feign being mean on the
court off the court be funny and all
that
i used to watch some charles oakley
something bill limberg
be stop being so like i don't want to
see like a troll
impede i don't want my seven foot three
[ __ ] 260 pound
center like making jokes being cute i
want like an
allure of fear i want a bad mama and ben
simmons
the kardashians [ __ ] him up you think
yes he was
do you think homeboy for uh the phoenix
who's [ __ ] with uh he better be
careful kendall
better be killed he's the first team all
bubble though he better be careful devin
booker d
booker d book be careful biggest hog in
the game pretty much yo
he's ill yeah no i'm saying like he's
known for having
the biggest hog in there devin booker
yeah really
how'd you hear that smoke i mean the
streets talk doug
d booker's so you're not your ears not
to the ground yes
your boy d booker's he's he's wow
good for him everybody know that well he
better be careful how does everybody
know that how do you
like why would you even get that
conversation around the water cool it's
just what kids talk about
about d booker's he he's hanging his
first team first team all all
all hanging stick and then first team
all bubble he was going oh
he's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
so so
for my pixel to back back to your
original question who's my picks
uh what where i'm a lakers fan what
where's him
are you i am a lakers i've been here
well denver's my squad right but you're
a lakers fan well i got a chair for a
team here it's either is my squad but
i'm a lakers fan
i cheer for lakers in los angeles i'm
here so you're here so
the lakers are your squad well no
denver's my squad i'm from born and
raised in denver right but they're not
going to go to the finals
okay lakers have a chance so if my
pleasure
if they did meet if let's say they root
for denver okay yeah
hopefully murray and djokovic go off
they're ill dope jamal's so
the joker's sick you know who else is
sick who got bumped
my man luca is a [ __ ] god he's
good
he made me want to like like reevaluate
like how come i didn't make it to the
nba he makes it look so easy and so
fun like i was like i could have been
that i'm 50. oh it's interesting
this one i'm thinking in my head this is
how [ __ ] up i'm thinking
i could have been like because he's a
white guy because he's slow with like
he's
he's nice with it but he's not really
explosive he's
ill yeah but he's so good he's sick i
love when that dude uh
marcus morris yeah was like [ __ ] your
pup get what do you say shut your punk
ass white boy up [ __ ] ass white boy
can't guard me yeah yeah i want it and i
thought they should have canceled them
oh really i mean not that i felt that
because i get the context of it in
sports in sports
i don't think anybody should be
cancelling sports at all but
but but if you're in this day and age
yeah you gotta cancel everybody you have
to
be because i thought lena dunham was
going to come out and call for his
cancellations
because if luca if luca would have said
shut your black ass up yeah and we have
a problem
he probably would never play again he
might be he at least
kicked him out of the bubble 100 percent
dude i thought it was [ __ ] and i
love them
both me too i love both of them but i
don't think you should do anything but
since they do
you gotta play it fair this [ __ ]
cancel culture
[ __ ] is is such [ __ ]
nonsense it's such [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
gonna just say this
okay obviously this this kid did not
deserve to be shot in the back seven
times jacob blake
he didn't deserve to be shot you could
have tackled him they did
no i mean when he was going to the car
like get on they try to tase them too
so get on some troy palamalo [ __ ] and
spear him get on some lauren taylor [ __ ]
and
sure be great if they were cops but sure
okay i'm just saying
okay but and then you could shoot once
you
that's the so the issue is not they
should have been apprehended the issue
is they shot
seven times right right i don't think
that i'm with you shouldn't show them
sometimes
was he doing criminal behavior well
that's my point were the cops called for
a reason
that's my point did the the female in
the the house
call because she was worried the reason
why charges
he has charges because he has a a rape
charge against that she called she
called the cops correct
she called the cops that being said i to
be clear did you need to shoot the
[ __ ] guy
seven times no not at all you could have
shot him once in the ass and i think he
would have stopped yeah at least he
didn't die though
thank god i know you could have shot him
in the league yeah uh
and there was kids in the car thank god
a bullet didn't listen
the whole thing's bad tragic that being
said
he's an alleged rapist a sexual abuser a
legend alleged sexual abuse
i think he has charges against him i'm
saying alleged i want to be very careful
go ahead
we have the uh uh former vice president
and his new vice president they go to
meet him
have an hour-long meeting with a sexual
abuser who's this
pence all right they met him yesterday
biden and camel
kamala harris met him what happened to
the [ __ ] me too
[ __ ] movement that that's the end of
the me too movement me too
well me too ate its own tale with alyssa
milano and uh
the the one the one girl who who uh rose
mcgowan
yeah they started fighting with each
other but like that was my me too
movement
i understand what happens to this guy is
is is i i am
not understand i'm a believer that it
shouldn't have happened
but why does [ __ ] biden
and kamala need to go meet with him just
just for for for phone for votes it's
the same thing as
why joe biden had all the [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] the people that you could
get to interview you could go to joe
rogan you could go to
all the bro any sort of broadcaster you
could go to charlemagne the god you
could go to
you know he didn't [ __ ] up and he
[ __ ] up he said well if i say you if
you don't listen to the iron rapper
stereo podcast
you ain't black if you don't listen to
the iron wrap poor stereo podcast
you're not black and that's basically
that would be i'd be the end of me
if i said that joe biden hadn't said
that be like what are you talking about
the [ __ ] are you talking about so out to
lunch he's just
doesn't now you know i have the iconic
nickname for donald trump
what but i'm confused i thought you were
anti-trump but now you're going hard at
biden so now i'm i i think you're both
stuck i'll tell you what
listen obviously i made up the the
iconic thinking for donald trump
dickstein donald trump okay
no viral that's gone viral it's great
yeah it's great good for you rolls off
the tongue yeah
dick stained donald trump sure november
3rd we have
the election yes put this on a poster
dick stained donald trump verse cadaver
joe
biden love it cadaver joe
you think i don't think he's gonna win i
don't know man you didn't see the trump
tapes this morning
oh what what what was he peeing on did
they release no no no the
the p-tapes haven't come out ptape's
gonna make me vote for him but carry on
if he was getting beat on it yeah if
he's either
either i'm in if he's getting peed on
you're voting for if he's peeing on him
not kidding
yeah i don't like that yeah but if he's
getting beat on like yeah
because you could relax we got a freak
on our hands right we got a real freak
we got a freak
i want that guy to run the free world
there's all sorts of [ __ ] that he was
interviewing the guy bob warden the all
the president's man guy
and listen i don't want to get no just
tell me just let me know what he said
he's saying he
he it's february 7th he's saying this is
bad
this is uh it's airborne he's saying
wild [ __ ] about about
this or about covet it's not good it's
it's not [ __ ] good but that being
said if i had to bet the house on who
would win
today i say dick's name donald trump i
think i think i think trump wins because
people dick saying donald trump is going
to defeat cadaver joe biden i agree
and you say why do i break both balls
i'll say one thing that
no i'm glad you did but and you know
what in the last six months
i be before trump
i never mentioned obama i didn't care
about politics i didn't know who the
the secretary of the house is the
speaker of the house i
i literally was completely uneducated
well to quote brian callum get involved
in politics
because they're getting involved with
you we're
quoting brian like oh and regurgitate
that from uh
again say that again you better get
involved with politics because they're
gonna get involved with you
no but let it let it let it like
marinate like where everybody's like wow
no it's not now he regurgitated that
quoting brian [ __ ]
quoted that from somebody else don't get
it twisted stole it he stole it right
okay but it's a good quote the thing
that i have because i'm with you because
i wasn't into
obama any of that stuff i didn't pay
attention you because you and also as
you get a little older
and you're paying taxes and all that
stuff especially taxes for but for me
like in the last six months i've spent
so much more time watching
all the news and let me tell you
something there's no difference between
[ __ ] disco don lemon
[ __ ] cuomo [ __ ] rachel maddow
that [ __ ] four-eyed [ __ ] like worm
that goes on uh before her
[ __ ] tucker carlson and sean hannity
they are all the same exact
same same thing they're just playing for
different teams they're just literally
as if you were a patriots fan correct
and i thought the patriots sucked and we
it was like skipping champion whichever
one you want to watch that's it
you're both getting just propaganda
[ __ ]
they do the same job and and and when
when when dixon says fake news
all three of those stations you have to
do so much work to even come up with a
an opinion of your own you have to watch
all of them and then go okay this is
what i think because
they're not giving you the real [ __ ]
deal i do i don't think it's not cool
no it's fake news and public media is
enemy number one but
you i don't think you can watch and get
a good opinion because they're both
so far-fetched they're both so
exaggerated like [ __ ] and you know what
i think that i think that's the problem
it's not the other thing i think people
like i just want the news give me some
statistics do some real [ __ ] give me
some snatch
who's ahead in the polls what's the
coven numbers uh i want to know all
about all the shootings of all races all
colors all creeds
i want to see uh the writers the
protesters i want to see the people that
are
i was thinking the other i swear i was
thinking about you the other day
i mean you you're kind of a big guy but
like these people that go up to people
and they flip their tables
and you see like like the protesters
like i was like they're going to flip
the wrong person's table
yeah they're going to they're going to
fl and well it's the same way as when
they loot and then finally someone fires
back
you're going to [ __ ] with the wrong
person on both sides on both sides it
doesn't matter
let me tell you something when you're
walking down the street with a gun
you're
you're putting yourself and other people
in jeopardy at a riot
go home like because if you're at a riot
you're and you have a gun
there you're you're you're amping things
up it's bad enough that there's a riot
but when you're out there like i'm going
to protect this
this gas station i'm going to do now
you're playing with and i don't care but
my thing is if you
own the get if you're getting no that
your family owns it that is i and i was
making this reference
the other day like remember the riots it
happened in the early 90s
did you see what the koreans did yeah
they were on top of their business
like this is our livelihood no but if
you [ __ ] with it we're going to totally
but if i say i'm going to go out there
to protect that mobile stuff
yeah then you're bugging and that's when
they get the people shot and they go
well this guy's a hero this guy's a
a white supremacist no no when you go
out like stay the [ __ ] in the house
that's where cops should come and play
or or national guard
correct because uh and and and the
little [ __ ]
the the i i love the people uh
especially the the white girls
it's so funny when they're out there in
portland and i love portland
i love it but when you're out there with
a hockey mask on
and like a [ __ ] shield and all this
stuff and you're throwing [ __ ] at the
cops and you're setting things on fire
and they come
don't go what the [ __ ] are you doing and
film it why are you doing this
[ __ ] yeah you don't hear that it says
go home but you're also playing the game
like that that's part of the rule they
think it's paintball or some [ __ ]
it's not paintball
listen i talk a lot of [ __ ] but in my
life i've gotten in trouble for certain
things in school when i was a kid i've
stolen
when i was a teenager when i stole and
got caught
i never said why are you doing this i
said here's the sushi package that i
stole in my
like and you stole sushi that happened
to me at avons
in hollywood when i first got to la i
got banned from the old
tower records on sunset they they
arrested me but the cops didn't come and
they they would like just don't come
back
here but but i didn't go why are you
doing this you know you're fighting i
[ __ ] stole a [ __ ] truck because
you're requesting you're playing the
game
but but um when you're like when you do
something wrong expect
uh ramifications 100 like if i smack the
[ __ ] out of you right now
i'm gonna suck you in your [ __ ] low
budget larry bird face and i wouldn't i
wouldn't say why are you doing that why
are you doing they're always like why
are you doing this
i saw this chick in a portland table she
was like these people were caught on
fire and the girl's like why are you
doing this she's like cara
cara i love you i like [ __ ] you're
going to jail
yes that's what happens well you're
playing the game you dummies
now pull up my instagram because you got
to put there was a woman there was an la
protest last night
oh yeah she offered to suck off the cops
see if you put your guns down
i'll suck your dick and women i'll eat
you too
this is so put my second one with the
woman this is great
this is la last night
wow if you take that badge off i'll suck
your dick
if you take that badge off like
you put by any means that's sir that's
she's like
malcolm x said by any means necessary
that's by any means she's waiting to
suck off the lap
that's a white girl i i think so it
looks
like a white girl yes her man's like
what the [ __ ]
yeah you know we didn't come out here
for you yeah what are you talking about
you want a way to make a change you want
to suck off all the police department
what the [ __ ] are you doing okay i just
read by autobiography of malcolm x
this is this is what i have told you my
skill sets yes this is what i mean she
didn't just
make a change one dick at a time and and
she said she'd eat the women
off too and the cops didn't respond
unfortunately no she wasn't
she wasn't able to get what she wanted
out of the deal but
um so we didn't get to your prediction
who's winning the nba championship and
also wait you know what i love what i
was going to say
carry on i was going to say this is when
you and me are talking politics
the people at home are like that's what
i want to hear like these guys are
they're educating them i know or like
god i hope after politics they jump into
kovitz
right but like i i like i just took away
a lot
listening to [ __ ] brendan shaw and
michael rapport break down
the political climate we didn't really
break it down we broke it down from a
very layman's
viewpoint yes right but i'm sure
everybody has the majority of the people
our opinions are better than these i
agree nba players
and like when lebron talks like bro how
do you not educate yourself on what's
going on
and what about china lebron what about
where your sneakers are made that's what
i'm saying dude
like if you're gonna if you're gonna be
the face of the
the mba and be the guy who makes a
change and say all the stuff
how do you not have someone in your ear
who's more educated on the topics at
hand
that gives you an opinion on what to
spurt out i don't
know kaepernick has that yeah a lot of
people have cardi b doesn't
cardi b interviewed uh cadaver jones she
got do you see
candidates yes split her the [ __ ]
i had said that oh i had said that isaac
why again why
are you letting card and carney be youth
and that's the question like if
i know nothing but if i got to interview
one of these people i would have
i would reach out to people and i would
have like [ __ ] real
questions to ask i wouldn't you know
cook her and all this [ __ ] nonsense
and
like she got and i would know that this
guy's playing me you're playing me you
want to
you want me to interview you that's what
he does they're pilot they have this
[ __ ] down that's what they do
they're all scumbags if he had a [ __ ]
dummy like you in front of him
sure he would chew you up spit you out
step on biden oh no if there's one
person that i could better than
like you there's one person i speak
better than hits [ __ ] joe biden but
he would
especially 77. he'd see i say i got this
big
this [ __ ] ape in front of me he's
like uh he'd be doing like
juggle tricks in front of you and [ __ ]
tell you what it'd be more challenging
than his cardi b interview
what was she thinking part of the
problem is them
even giving her that platform to
interview that's what i'm saying because
people go ah
[ __ ] dude but he's thinking i'm going to
get her it's the shit's just
that's what i'm saying you know the best
thing brian could do and i don't know
how it would go and i i would have met i
would
i would bet my bottom daughter bottom
dollar they reached out to rogan
because rogan had bernie sanders on uh
trump retweeted rogan you see him
retweet rogan's yeah his is to his uh
with how he said how biden's kind of if
you're going i think he said going on a
hike he's that flashlight where you yeah
yeah yeah keep flickering out yeah i
think it doesn't end well
yeah flashlight trump blasted that out i
would imagine they've reached out to
havrogun because that would
have rogan he would like dude he would
eat him
alive joe would joe would eat by the way
yeah i know
i i think journalists would i think i
think honestly
because he's he's a beat slow well
that's why they're not going to let him
uh debate with trump i thought they were
debating i heard they weren't
who the [ __ ] knows again again guys
we're we're giving you the [ __ ]
up-to-date the real yeah is he is he
debating him
i think i i don't know i don't know but
i do know if they do how to be a comedy
central rose
great the one thing trump is good at is
talk [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
being entertaining he would eat him
alive and that's why they don't want to
do it they should put that [ __ ] on
pay-per-view and all the money goes to a
covet thing
i'd pay for that everybody would it
would be like ali frazier but back to
lebron it's like how
how are you gonna speak on these issues
or like when when milwaukee protests
like hold on
you guys don't have all the issues you
don't have all the details and you guys
gonna walk out over this
i think is the culmination and then how
stupid they had to go back the next day
and then and you and how the rumor was
that lebron
didn't like that milwaukee protested
before
yes so he didn't tell him and he wanted
to be the the
and then it came out was like i was i'm
gonna say this i have a friend who's in
the nba
this is what he said to me about lebron
and i quote the fakest guy
in the league end quote good player
though
ridiculous player great player sick not
as good as jordan
not as good as jordan doesn't it seem
like the last dance was like [ __ ]
three years ago did you watch that in
like uh
drool oh god i couldn't get enough of it
me neither
six episodes is not enough i watched it
i wanted 26. i've watched it twice now
i've watched the whole thing i watched
an episode and then i'd watch it at
least three times i didn't like how they
did my boy scottie pippen though
what about it i'm just saying they like
they highlighted like he was a
baller dude and they highlighted like a
lot of his like
a lot of his downfalls like he didn't
want to play in the game he didn't want
to play in the game he
made bad deals i didn't know he came
from like he
you know did you know he made more money
in his mba nba career than jordan did
when he left and went to right because
he got mad
but he got he had [ __ ] up uh [ __ ]
happen to him financially afterwards
he lost money and all that stuff it's a
bummer
but back back to your original question
let's move on from politics yeah
just dying to hear what's this president
trump and joseph are by well debate
with a single monarch
i can't wait for that i got to put that
in my phone i can't wait that shit's
going to literally be the one
that's so entertaining yeah chris
wallace not not biggie but
the the the journalist chris wallace i
can't wait that's gonna be bug the [ __ ]
out it's gonna be so entertaining
they're gonna have you if you don't like
politics
and they're gonna come essential oh
they're gonna be pumped up both of them
on
so much [ __ ] like vitamin drips i bet
you a lot like even that biting still
gonna [ __ ] up
because he's asked for a teleprompter
trump is going to be doing that
he's like on some like deviant don
rickles [ __ ]
he's like uh he's he's you can't talk he
can talk that [ __ ] the new york guy did
yo that [ __ ] he could talk that [ __ ]
that that tulsa
uh uh a speech that he gave in that
arena when everybody
i was watching that [ __ ] it was like yo
he was up there for an hour and 45
minutes
think about that beast yo
yo he didn't even take a sip of water
nothing that's a [ __ ]
he doesn't sweat he's not in shape i
mean when you do shows you need water
dude what you need i'm sweaty this is a
[ __ ] savage
and he's powering through it 140 nothing
and that's it we'll move forward we'll
move forward but that's back to lebron
so fake the
fakest guy in the bay from your nba
friend which i've heard before
my thing with him being the forefront of
this whole movement they're trying to do
it's like how is he not more educated on
the subject and and
and like that's my issue it's like all
right dude and then also you
you talk about human rights but then
when it comes to hong kong you don't
even address it because
it's gonna [ __ ] up your bottom dollar
that's why i can't [ __ ] with people
and that's why i can't [ __ ] with people
i can't [ __ ] with people i cannot [ __ ]
with people you gotta
[ __ ] with the nba if i watch it but i
don't listen i watch it like it's like
you know like there's actors there's uh
musicians
i don't give a [ __ ] i watch the goddamn
i'm a fan like this [ __ ]
eric trump yesterday go oh no watching
the nfl who cares
okays they're taking a knee who gives a
[ __ ] i don't watch the [ __ ] gun
watching the game
yeah i don't care i don't watch the the
pre stuff post stuff i watch the
watching the [ __ ] games like what
gets you hyped the games
the thrill of victory the agony of
defeat i'm watching the [ __ ] you're not
taking that away from me it's like
with new balance like at one point they
were saying that new balance back
i'm like [ __ ] i don't give a
flying [ __ ] i'm wearing the goddamn
sneakers
my feet are flat they're comfortable i
don't give a [ __ ]
like oh my 60 from my pair of sneakers
what the [ __ ]
i mean if you investigated every single
thing i mean you would
give me a [ __ ] break man i'm watching
i'm i'm watching the games in my new
battle but
what i do financially again i'm watching
nfl nba
ufc mlb i don't give a [ __ ] about
anything none of it
but but if i'm an owner if i'm
if i'm a homeboy who who runs jerry
jones
jerry jones and it's affecting my bottom
dollar it's a conversation you have to
have because it's like con because it's
going to affect your dollar too
exactly defensive tackle and also in the
nba like what people don't realize in
the nba they're 50 50.
with their with the money yeah they're
basically partners with nba
they have the best deal so the players
are partners with the nba
so the profit sharing 50 50. wow so when
they protest those games
the owner's like all right we we can do
that but your
your payment your salary is based off
playing this many games and these tv
wow now you guys are doing that you're
getting you're not we can't pay you the
same i didn't know that yeah
so so like they're you're basically next
season they're gonna think about it
you're basically protesting yourself
interesting and also if you guys don't
play you don't have any platform to say
anything like george hill was so
from from the from the bucks he was one
of the like the the
he was a spokesperson from the bucks so
articulate
uh passionate clearly thought out and
just
emotional but emotionally articulate you
know i get emotional sometimes i
but he was just and it's like george
hill if you left
like no one knows who you are like they
know they know cp
they know you know a few people like
they know lebron and stuff like georgia
you
people you have a voice in all this and
the only way you have a voice is if
you're playing
the only one who doesn't is really
lebron because he has a hundred
transcendent
six million followers but the rest of
them don't anyway
make your [ __ ] prediction but you're
dragging it out i'm not trying to keep
going
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dick stain all right
[ __ ] the cadaver here's my thing
what where is mouth being a lakers face
make a prediction but here's my thing
let's make a prediction who's winning
the championship here no it's too tough
to say that because
i in order for the lakers to beat the
clippers
we got a bank on their bench and rondo
going off every [ __ ] night can you
make it can they do it
or not gun to the head uh it's gonna be
clippers
versus no no no no no who's winning the
title i'm gonna win one team
i'll go boston i'm hoping boston does
wins the nba title that's what i'm
hoping
i think they're playing the best team
ball okay now are they going they're
probably the biggest dogs to do it
okay but i can't you what are you going
to say the clippers
rewind this great take right in time
that's who i think oh he's going to win
the championship oh
everybody does okay the best team but
i've been
but it's the bubble so to me it's like
the bet whoever's playing the best as a
unit
which is boston celtics right now right
now but toronto that series ain't over
don't think that [ __ ] is over i hope
it's over it ain't [ __ ] over
that [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] over and that's
the it's a long
end winding bubble and that's the beauty
of the bubble for s fans for the players
it sucks
for the players it sucks but guys nba
players and i know there's plenty of you
watching
you're not missing anything else there's
nothing dude trust me
your favorite coffee spot it's all
locked in your favorite restaurant
i guess some of you young guys with the
women cool i understand that i know
they've let in a few weeks
depends what city you're in if you're in
texas if you're in florida if you're in
the red states
it's popping if you're in salt lake it's
popping popping but if you're in la it's
definitely you don't want to be in l.a
don't you don't want to be in new york
those are the best two cities
miami's [ __ ] like so really you know
unless you want to go hang out if you
even if you don't play for the utah jazz
you want to go hang out in salt lake no
disrespect to soul lake other than that
you're not missing anything
they love to spend their off time in la
trust me fellas
there ain't [ __ ] out here so you're
taking clippers i got the clippers
that took 45 minutes
well they got they got the deepest you
know bench lou williams they got the
they're playing
they're built for it and they got the
the the ancillary player i mean they got
the sixth man of the year they got the
other six man of the year they're
balling
um ufc what's what's the next big night
uh style bender versus uh paula costa
and that's in uh ufc uh fight island it
in
abu dhabi yeah jesus christ why don't
they just do
why do they do abu dhabi and not just
keep it in vegas
for the international fighters so
they'll have to fly all the way to vegas
because like
style better israel is in new zealand he
flies there to easier flight
uh for polo costa brazil it's easier
there so
so who who do you got in that fight uh
israel i think it's a perfect fight for
him
he could do his [ __ ] yeah yeah he he
does well against aggressive guys
but ufc is popping popping yeah fights
all the time [ __ ] big fights then you
got the dana white contender series
it's good during the week and they're
crushing it man are you watching the
contendership
i haven't been watching it's good why is
it good because
were you a ultimate fighter fan yes so
if you like like if you're an actual
hardcore fan it's
just like these guys are legit fighters
like i think last night there's this
russian dude versus brazilian dude
the russian dude is like 14-0 brazilian
dudes 15-0
and they're fighting for a ufc contract
that night so these boys come to
fight they're like fighting and there's
no there's no it's not like you know
where the
ultimate fire there's a build-up of
characters guys weren't very good
they're just interested that's how you
were i found you
yeah but these guys are like fighting
fight
they're coming to fight because if they
win that fight they get a contract that
night danny goes yeah here's the
contract
so these boys are scratching i have to
watch it how many of them
and they also have like the what's who's
who who's the girl that i like laura
senko laura sanchez
they have she's like the she comes into
the ring but she also does commentary
like she's like
mvp of that thing she's a beast okay so
i'm hoping they take
her and implant her into the actual ufc
production is this chick right here
she could fight she was a fighter too
she well she was a fighter but she's a
commentator now okay okay she's
by far i think the mvp of the contender
series okay because you what the whole
production thing is really good but
she's like one of the best things and
what uh
what about my man khabib like if you're
a fighter and how old is khabib
uh 30 was he 32 don't you
as a fighter like think like i need to
fight 32
it's been how long has it been since he
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of conor
mcgregor
it's been almost two years two years
well he's fought no not it's over a year
let's see it's like a year it's year and
it's like five doesn't
right september 2019. that was his last
fight
abu dhabi i forgot his father passed
away okay which was a big deal and he
but he had that one fight that got
cancelled with
tony ferguson right which was
and then now he's fine don't you get
antsy wouldn't you be antsy to fight how
do you keep yourself
yeah how do you keep yourself like fight
ready because
these guys it's not like you could
practice can you practice
no but you can never you can stay in
shape right yeah
but he also right so ramadan right he's
super
his religion so the muslim religion so
ramadan so he can't fight during that
time
which is what august i think and then
his father passed away so he's dealing
with that
he promised he only has two fights left
he wants to retire 30-0 he's 28 no now
so then he has this yeah oh i'm sorry
ramadan's april 12th to
you don't want to [ __ ] that up no do not
get that correct people
get it right so you know he has a lot of
other x factors going on but his father
passed away he's the biggest deal
okay but then he and then also i think
they're good maybe do it at the apec
center in vegas
but when they do fight when he fights
justin gaichi
stylishkey it's his toughest test to
date it's a
why geichi's just a [ __ ]
heavy-handed great wrestling great
cardio can go all five rounds
just beat the brakes off tony ferguson
right beat the [ __ ] out
right right right and then you know and
he's more active so like it's a tough
fight for khabib man
and then already you know the [ __ ]
fans were like oh khabib vs
gsp it's like dude he has to get through
this gsp
leave it leave it alone i know gsp needs
to leave it alone
i know it's crazy leave it why are we is
he not having money
he has money then why are you still
fighting he doesn't look right
and he's 39 and he'd have to cut to 55.
while out you're done you think
you should be done he should be done he
don't look right like he gets
when he was young he would beat his hair
out no but i'm saying like
one of the last two fights he had i mean
he was in there like
i'm like you're supposed to be you look
thick against michael bismay it didn't
it wasn't
good no didn't look like i and i think
if he were to cut to 55 he
it'd be a problem for him especially
fight khabib at 55. no that's a bad idea
don't do that and conor says he's done
done no well you know how connor is
if if gaichi wins i bet they do conor uh
gaichi
because it's a good it's a better
matchup for conor he doesn't want khabib
it's a tougher fight but he does want he
that's all he's holding out for is the
winner
of khabib gaichi that he's like i'm
going to fight he [ __ ] him up
yeah he [ __ ] him up he did and he
didn't if you look at the house
so because like you know if you're balls
deep
connor fan which i am like he barely he
really didn't train
his take down defense connor didn't
train whose fault is that
you're fighting a guy but it's his but
imagine him with a full camp but also
his takedown defense was pretty [ __ ]
good yes i mean he's sick
but when he had him in that
[ __ ] bear claw oh i know
but you give him a full camp like
there's hope
there's always hope but there's hope if
gay two were to beat
khabib gaichi does not in it does not
partake in takedowns doesn't want to do
it doesn't take anybody down
he'll sit and trade with connor that's
what connor [ __ ] lives for so if
you're a connor fan you want him to get
the belt
the easiest pathway which isn't easy but
if you're a connor fan
would be if gates you were to win and
what if conor gates and what about um
jones isn't he fighting is heavyweight
he's going to go up to heavyweight who's
he going to fight
uh he'll fight uh stipe right away so i
bet he waits to
step and francis fighting to fight the
winner of that stipe's the guy who just
beat dc
right yes now i said something that
people got so [ __ ] offended i want to
throw this i can't wait
i said because joe rogan and the ufc and
we've been talking about this
since i first came on the show i said
about round and round i said how can you
say
anyone's the greatest of all time that's
what we do the greatest of all time
and she's literally never taken a punch
and as soon as she took a punch
the first time rhonda got punched done
game over
okay now people say dc the greatest of
all time
the greatest of all time choose your
words carefully now i'm gonna choose my
words you're in sparta
choose your words carefully i will kick
it i just had dc on my show that's my
guy
i [ __ ] training partners i [ __ ] with
dc but he's lost
big fights but he's one big fight i know
but and you can how could you say the
greatest of all time you could say
let me one of if you say one of i'm cool
with it well they should say one of them
they don't they say
that's nothing that's like lebron but
but they'll say steepy like they were
like the rogan said before the greatest
heavyweight of all time yeah and i'm
like
okay so is steep be the greatest
heavyweight of all he is but
no he's the champion no he's the
greatest of all time if you look yeah
well he let me educate you on dc for a
second so you know
let me do a favor i i i said that he's
one of
yeah but what he was fighting for if you
if he were to beat stephen he would ride
off in the sense that he's the greatest
ever do it
because but after the last loss when he
got [ __ ] the [ __ ] knocked out of him
it's like but he was winning all the
rounds and then
and then but before that he knocked him
out i was there one and one
i got it and then he didn't fight him
again no no
he didn't what was that dude's name who
the dude who knocked him out
who knocked two l who knocked out dc jon
jones
no no no no no he's only lost to jon
jones and stephen john jones twice
we don't know what he was on or not on
allegedly because
but he lost those fights i don't know
why john's the grace of all time
that's what i'm saying and then when
john goes to heaven he'll be the
greatest fault that's why nobody's
beating john
so why so why like because john hasn't
got a heavyweight yet but as of right
now for heavyweight you gotta realize dc
was a light heavyweight his entire
career
fought in the in the in the strikeforce
grand prix fought the best of the best
won that and was the was the biggest
underdog
beat beat josh barnett bigfoot silva
beat the [ __ ] out of these dudes
goes to ufc as a heavyweight beats frank
mayer beats roy jones
then goes to light heavyweight becomes
champion at light heavyweight beats
everybody not named jon jones right
b gus finn beat all these guys anthony
rumble johnson
and then goes to heavyweight knocks out
stephen
right gets the belt and then fights him
twice and loses
but
everything should be everything should
be one of them i agree unless there's
you agree that in basketball too
it's hard to see yes see it's team
sports so you're saying like
floyd mayweather [ __ ] 49 you
could say
i mean in his division he's the greatest
of all time whether you like him or not
all that [ __ ] personality
all that [ __ ] but i'm just saying like
in his division now you say oh is he
could he fight muhammad ali was like i'm
not talking to you yeah that's right
you're stupid yeah i hate you you sound
stupid there's nothing worse you sound
dumb but but
you know like with individual sports i
think you can say it
you can't argue a heavyweight versus a
flyweight but if you're arguing
heavyweight heavyweight this is where
the argument gets weird because if you
go steep is the grace of all times like
well hold on
because stylistically cain velasquez
when he was in his prime would give
stipe
all the problems to me the if if they
went you got to pick one guy
that would beat anybody in the world in
their book would you say is it happening
is that the greatest we've ever seen
okay so that's what i'm talking and if
you talk to dc
who came up with kane they're training
partners and they're both heavyweights
he would say kane vlaska that's what i'm
talking i just don't like that the great
they're fighting it's inviting us
because nobody's saying it about
steeping
sells pay-per-views i understand so you
used to train with dc
yeah and stipe both of them jesus christ
it's like what like wrestling
everything like what would you do punch
spar wrestle like do what
yeah like chill out like you do what you
know
just trying to get training like yeah
and you roll around yeah
but here's the here's what's interesting
like you're like you're on him
and he's on you yeah yeah you're getting
into dude you know what's weird with
basketball is
when you hear players talk they say the
best guy in the gym as far as like
pick up basketball is carmelo anthony i
wouldn't be surprised
everyone and their mom goes in his prime
but did you steve kergo is the best
player i've ever been around
ever and he's been around jordan he's
around steph curry
he's around clay thompson he said durant
right durant
he was the best the most directed player
arguably i mean he's
suit he's you [ __ ] idiots the
slim reaper is seven he wants to be
listed at 6 11. because he doesn't like
being called seven
he's every bit of seven foot he's in the
other one
this one oh dude when they went for the
run i i'm just
i'm just saying as far as what
highlights that people want to see
jump shots people don't want i'm saying
for these kids the three point
oh i i get it oh and i think the
majority people but like
lebron you're like god like even listen
yeah
you know occasionally you'll get durant
duncan but not really it's a lot of
mid-range or a lot of threes
and it's and because it's just it
doesn't look as aesthetically pleasing
as
even let's say a steph curry because
he's so little
or a harden it's so it's but kevin
durant
come come whenever this nba starts back
up again he'll remind everybody how
[ __ ] stupid he is yeah he's my
favorite he's sick he's my favorite he's
a [ __ ]
and seven feet in the hands do you think
uh giannis goes to golden state
or you think he stays i think he's gonna
stay really i think he's going to stay
he just seems like that type of person i
don't know
you know what's weird to me is like
everyone's on his nuts like oh defensive
play of the year
he's win back-to-back mvps has one bad
game like he's basically scottie pippen
it's like you [ __ ] idiot
shut up richard hamilton how crazy is
that just shut up and then but then
other
players jumped on it yeah i mean and
then also like being
he's not just sh and also young
everybody needs a
super young but he also like name the
other best player on his team
like you look at these other teams
there's [ __ ] clippers are
stacked yes lakers are stacked yes yeah
and what's his name on on milwaukee with
the with the [ __ ] up hairline who
looks like he's 50
but he's only 26 middleton he's good but
he's good but on another
i i understand that giannis is sick he
needs to figure out they might need to
add a piece
going to the to the golden state this
early if how old is [ __ ]
honest 24 he's young 25 freak he's a
[ __ ] but they say golden state's
gonna trade the second round pick
and then get giannis or they they were
saying the rumors but who knows they
said
they were gonna trade the second pick to
the sixers and the six is going to uh
trade ben simmons
either way it's like golden state chill
the [ __ ] out but but but if they get ben
simmons and ben simmons can't shoot
they don't he ain't kevin durant ben
simmons ben simmons
we don't need another shooter we but i'm
just saying we
i'm just saying curry and clay will take
the shot yes defense
layups well because ben simmons plays
good deals team all defense brother he's
uh he he he needs to get away from
philly and stay away from those [ __ ]
kardashians they'll [ __ ] yeah they
[ __ ] his brain up
they [ __ ] this are you sad the
kardashians they keep up with kadashas
you don't like enough with the
kardashians yeah them
uh the [ __ ] chloe kylie [ __ ]
kendall
kendall caitlin oh the whole crew well
caitlin's caitlin's
went away but caitlin was like i'm i'm
all sad right i don't want to i'm so
don't want to be a party i'm going to
[ __ ] get a sex change
that's how much i adopted i can't stand
you [ __ ] i'm going to do this
courtney just just enough enough and
like me and my wife were having this
discussion which just
goes to show how much uh more time than
we need to spend around each other we
that we're having these discussions sure
about like will they lose their fame i
go it's just one nip one nitpick
no they're instagram and then kanye and
that ain't a normal cough brother that
ain't
normal that you have the black lung pop
yeah that's all right you'll be all
right oh
[ __ ] i'm good no i'm sure can you pull
some coffee from another no i would just
show people
i'm a perpetual call for i mean it
doesn't matter we've all had it here
my man just don't do you want optics
i i i don't want yeah i want wipe anyway
all right i'm i'm glad move the [ __ ] on
with your life
go deal with your husband he's he's gone
uh he's out to lunch
gonzo gonzo gonzo and it was like well
why are you saying him crazy because
he's an outside the box thinker no
shows the guy on the corner when i came
into the studio he
when he was really outside the box he
was nude out there playing
he's just not kind he's outside the box
too he's kicking some wild [ __ ] to
himself
yeah so don't talk to me about [ __ ]
with you about yeezy let's do some
current events jen
let me people before we do that sure
yeah no it's not good it's fine
don't worry about the [ __ ] are we still
rolling yeah we can't we can be
[ __ ] yeah all right this is the way it
should be the fighter and the kid
uh a michael rapport all everything uh
edition of the show
i mean it's it's people say why do you
do it like it's kind of like you know
like when they say oh can you give the
a month to the aspca and i go yes i like
to donate my time
uh donate my money and all this that's
why i keep coming
uh back to this [ __ ] hell hole here
and to do it by myself i know fans are
relieved
uh to see uh that [ __ ] gorilla go to
the bathroom and do whatever he's doing
in there and tightening
and you know there's something about
brendan's job is like when he's in the
bathroom it's not just
in the [ __ ] bathroom you know he's
like primping and i'm like for what i
like for what are you a [ __ ] barbie
doll
like no one cares just get sit the [ __ ]
down so we can continue the show
those protest videos like that [ __ ] last
night
they crack me up in the morning i mean
they make me laugh like literally make
me laugh this one dude in portland was
rapping
in front of the cop's face i was like if
the cop had grabbed the mic and started
just like flowing back
it would have been the best [ __ ]
because how could you be keep a straight
face with this [ __ ]
but also to your point though it's like
when they're protesting then cops fight
back like how can you do this what am i
doing there you're playing the game you
just set a fire to the po
it's like going to the pool and being
pissed if you get splashed it's like
dude
this is the game if i started if i lit
this on fire here and you threw me into
the [ __ ] and you're like why would
you do what are you doing this for
why are you doing this to leave me alone
it's so strange what do you got jen
okay so um the creative
director i believe that's his title for
uh off-white virgil
louis vuitton uh oh yeah and he created
he he created the off-whites
he created those don't point to your
shoes like they're off lights but i feel
like those
those are but that whole off-white thing
virgil yo
i i [ __ ] with you do you not have any
off fights i have off whites but i want
to be on that list
virgil me too bro listen we don't enjoy
getting [ __ ] on like
uh odell beckham and you send him shoes
virgil i [ __ ] with you
hard from day one and i know there's a
lot of people on your list that could go
ahead
and i'm not even saying this [ __ ] no no
but no we're together virgil i please i
want to be on that
that list do you know what list i'm
talking about not that [ __ ] like
oh the secondary list i want to be on
your [ __ ] list
because he he makes that fire i don't
even want to be on the louis vuitton
list i don't know i don't know
i just want some sneakers i just want
access to the nike off-white collabs
no the only i'll pay for it the only way
to really get him is to be on the
[ __ ] list yeah you're right
i mean paying for him is what i'm doing
now i want to be on that list just for
the sneakers again
i don't want any what is he louis
vuitton he's the head creative director
i don't want any clothing i don't i
don't want to i'm not asking for a free
card
she's going to fit in anyways and i
actually i don't even want the the white
off-whites anything
dark the black off-whites the gray
off-white so i'm being real specific
this is
this selfish uh i said i would pay for
him you [ __ ] no
i'm not a freeloader like this one
virgil give me access and i'll pay
i don't want before they sell out i
don't want to pay i'm not i'm not saying
he's going to flip them and resell them
like a [ __ ] box
i'm going to actually wear them dark
i just want the dark colored off-white
anything with reds
blacks blues grays anything like that
the white on white off-whites i don't
know
you i don't want them give them to
somebody else
so he's he's a talented [ __ ] guy he
really is
i mean to have that kind of creative
mind in like designing cars and clothes
and sneakers
and you know he designed drake's plane
did he really
nuts it's a dope plane how about drake
got that plane that giant planet
said thanks haters you can't say
anything about him
no drake no [ __ ] no
okay back to story yeah yeah i'd be
worried
virgil did a collab with mercedes where
he made a g
wagon and they're going to auction it
off for between 60 to 80 000
so they could give back to a charity
wait wait wait someone's going to offer
more than wait but that's yeah is that
starting starting is going to be like 60
grand to 80 grand
and then all the pros that's like an art
piece yeah yeah it's not going to be
like a real
is it a toy it's a real [ __ ] way
right now it's a car that's going to be
a real car
they're going to make it as a real car
but to my understanding it's more of an
art piece
always done for really dropping if it
don't drive
i ain't paying no money for the [ __ ]
thing i don't i don't care what you're
[ __ ] paying
now you're paying [ __ ] you're paying
[ __ ] [ __ ] you want the shoe sir
i'll bid but somebody got a bid after me
yeah i was like 95 000
goes to michael rappaport i'm like ah
what's this
he also did a collab with them for some
gloves that [ __ ] is all dope
all i want is that's lewis hamilton
style there all i want
is is is the sneakers that's yeah me too
i don't know i'm trying to have this
virtually i don't want the cars i mean
if i could afford to play not [ __ ] with
that but
yeah i i i can't i support it i support
it but
g wagon's a bit of a chick car but the
new g
wagon though have you seen the new g
well i have it it is
you have it yeah it's a bit of a chick
car is it you turn on there's like all
these neon lights and you can mess with
the lights it's like pink purple
uh you know orange you have the new sh
this my girl's favorite car so when you
when you went to mike did you have your
scarf on
oh yeah that's probably why you bought
it yep go ahead go ahead
all right next one yeah what else you
got chin so
this man came up with the name jelly
belly and the candy company actually
bought it off of him
he's currently holding a raffle similar
to charlie and the chocolate factory
nah i see him i'm not [ __ ] with you
man it's very sketchy because yeah i can
already tell you from the picture it's
sketchy
i'm not i have i don't give a [ __ ] what
you came up i don't trust this guy
i can tell you from the picture and i'm
not even looking at a close-up that this
guy's
up to no good so what's he trying to
he's trying to searching off the
he is saying that he has a factory
somewhere in florida
that he's going to give away and he's
going to teach someone how to make
their own candy business and you have to
pay
for these riddles okay each state gets a
certain amount
i [ __ ] out of here
you pay for a riddle and you try to find
a golden i'd rather bid on that [ __ ]
car for 100 g's than this [ __ ] golden
look at this guy
and he came up with this business idea
and after
if you find a golden ticket you get five
thousand dollars and you're in the
running to then
win the candy fast how much is it worth
do we have the idea no he's actually
coming out saying that
he would be lucky to break even and he
just wants to show somebody how to
during the corona virus right
okay the [ __ ] out of here take a walk
take a walk and take a shower
uh he would make two thousand dollars
but it would cover the cost of blah blah
blah blah blah [ __ ]
what else you got um ellen degeneres is
being her show is being renewed for 18th
season
bro have you seen the new and listen i'm
not i don't think she'd lose her job i'm
not about this cancer culture me neither
but have you
seen the new [ __ ] when she's running the
show at her house
the way she treat people it's for reals
the devil wears prada movie
she is a vibe they have do they have
video of it or tapes
no but they have uh employees that are
saying it oh dude
i'm not surprised i don't want her to
lose her job i'm not surprised
i don't think she should be kicked off
not with that [ __ ] yeah like if people
want to keep watching us she
people should have the right to say to
change and to grow
not you're gonna go to louis c.k island
yes you know i
i don't believe in that [ __ ] you know uh
there's there's breaking laws
there's all those things you're an
[ __ ] okay people
chose to be treated like an [ __ ] i
get when it's coming at you
i get when it's coming at you you don't
know how to act okay
i understand that i understand that but
she should be able to uh acknowledge it
apologize
and move forward and if people want to
hopefully do better but also if people
are going to apply for the job
knowing that she's an [ __ ] like
that's that's it all right
she's still doing the damn thing and
what do you get and and like it's like
if you
and and the reality is if like if you
don't have real proof
real evidence in this day and age it's
like i need to hear or see some tapes
you have like 60 employees though
okay one guy had the best tweet he goes
uh
anybody moving to california there's two
things i can assure you
one you're getting a parking ticket and
two you're gonna hear terrible stories
about ellen
it's so true like as soon as you touch
down in l.a like you how about ellen
you're like
well the lady that dances right yeah
they got mad at me when i didn't dance i
did her show once oh did you really
i didn't know i had never seen that i
didn't know you had to [ __ ] do any
research
i would [ __ ] go out there and make an
[ __ ] of myself
they were interviewing you yeah what a
big deal
all right okay so i didn't dance i
haven't been back since but was ellen
nice to you
you know on tv she even what did she
talk to you before
hey how are you maybe you know i i can't
remember that means i don't think it was
not she treated you like the youtube
star
yes yeah yes no yeah i didn't have a br
but the producer they were like
you didn't dance you know ellen thought
you were going to dance i was like i
didn't get the [ __ ] memo like i
didn't so i don't feel like dancing
[ __ ]
i i'm not just interviewing me yeah i
have you wanted me to look like an
[ __ ]
okay just treat me bad but you know when
the camera's on i'll take that
what else you got all right this one has
to do with mike oh
uh john boyega star wars actor yes and
you tweeted with them
yes so he was complaining that disney's
not using black people
like the way they should it's just kind
of like they're parading them like
they're going to be a part of this
character died off he was upset was it
did it die offered to get cut i don't
know i don't
know this is what happened john boyega
who who i think is a good actor
do i think he's um the next thing or
sir lawrence olivier no i think he's a
good actor good looking kid
he's done some good stuff has a nice
career so far i think he's a good actor
he gets cast uh as the what what was
supposed to be a very big part in star
wars
which right away you have cache to work
in films and tv
for the next 10 years of your life
that's like if you're on the poster of a
star wars movie the main
dude i don't care if your your part was
supposed to be in every scene and it was
cut down to 20 scenes
if you're on that poster that is credit
yes to your career yes you can literally
get things made
because of that yes this is a humongous
deal
he was in i think one or two of them
maybe three of them i don't [ __ ] with
star wars i don't [ __ ] with demons i
don't [ __ ] with lightning i don't [ __ ]
with anything i saw chewbacca when i was
a kid
that's it i'm done i'm not going to see
you know uh
for this i'm done it's true i'm out but
but so he said this thing on in an
interview i read the interview
and i tweeted at him i was like yo as an
actor
uh we are i i'm paraphrasing what i said
i said yo this is
exactly what it says yo my man you have
done so much in such a short period of
time congratulations but you're not the
first actor
to have an unnuanced uh you're but
you're not the first actor to have an
unnuanced character
in a star wars movie hashtag benicio del
toro welcome to show business
[ __ ] doesn't always go your way and then
he said did you read the article
uh uh thanks for the additional list
thanks for the addition a little
additional name to my list talking about
benicio you struggle with reading no but
i can't see it and then i tweeted back i
was like
yeah i read the article that's why i
tweeted at you it's show business
things don't always work out your way uh
the way you plan it happens to all of us
all of us all actors all of us again be
grateful for all you've done which is a
lot more than tons of great actors of
all races
who've also had roles cut out and will
continue to
the point is is uh and then this turned
into a racial thing
you're telling it's racial because
everything's [ __ ] racial
you're telling a black man to be
grateful how dare you talk to a black
man like this and i was talking to him
as an actor i'm kicking it to him like
this
first of all you ain't denzel you ain't
you
you you're not [ __ ] showing up and
you're a nice actor you're good
you don't pop no disrespect he's good
he'll have a great career he's good look
he's a good actor
he's not [ __ ] he's not robert de niro
in his prime he's not tupac and juice
yeah he's a good actor
okay and and i've had roles cut down
every actor there's not one actor alive
who can say oh i did this movie and they
cut down certain scenes i did this show
and they
it's you're not the director of the
producer the other day that's the
business
but i also think you have a good
reference and uh platform to talk from
because how long have you been acting
30 years 30 years 30 years and and you
were talking to him as like
i just said it isn't it's this isn't a
race thing it turned into this whole
race thing you're telling a black man to
be grateful
and then so then i tell those people
that say that to me you know what my
standard line is
suck my dick that's fair suck my [ __ ]
dick go [ __ ] yourself it's
either suck my dick or go [ __ ] yourself
because you're turning this into a
racing i'm kicking it to them as an
actor they're reaching
you're reaching they're reaching and i
made it clear and actually proof read
what
what i wrote which is uh doesn't happen
99.9 percent of the time
when you wanted to though because i was
clear because i knew when i i said it
happens to all of us of all races yes
and somehow some way it turns into a
race damage
go suck my [ __ ] twitter dick suck
this twitter dick i don't even see it
i don't i don't even entertain you
you're not even on there right no i mean
i'm on there
you pop in for a deliberate reason i i
post whatever my shows or
what i'm doing so what would be your
tweet for
michael rapport co-hosting re read it to
me out loud go ahead
uh come up with it right now come up
with a right go ahead i want to see if
it's if it's acceptable and exciting
enough i i would post that and go hey
what's the name john
boyega what's going on you don't know
how to say a black man's name
you're [ __ ] racist well i just say
hey hey john
rap suck come come co-host no that's not
gonna work
go again i want to know what the tweet's
going to say to get the [ __ ] fans get
the followers
you better at me you [ __ ] well i always
at you okay go ahead
uh on the next fighter in the cage let's
find the kid
rap gives this hot take on the clippers
winning the nba championship that's not
going to bring anybody to watch
god damn it and are you happy with that
take no i'm not the clippers
oh my god go all right what else you got
man yeah what else you got i got a
[ __ ] heart out here
all right canelo alvarez suing his
promoter oscar de la hoya
and things for like 280 million so he
signed the biggest
north american deal of all time 365
million dollars
and right when he signed everyone went
uh can the zone
cash that check it is that gonna happen
turns out
it's not gonna happen he's a free agent
now and he's suing us he's out of the
zone
well de zone's done his own belly up
so now you know canelo sued him for the
money that he was promised
wow but now does now canelo can play
ball he can come to showtime
come to you know espn but he's going to
be the biggest free agent in a long ass
time they're going to be like you want
me he's the best fighter on the planet
yes it's just boxing is not
it's not what it used to be and and you
know nowhere near and no disrespect you
need
a in america you need american champions
you need american champions he's great
he barely speaks uh english yeah
no disrespect i'm just saying
or worldwide appeal and but americans
want to root for americans unless it's
tyson fury and then it becomes
race versus deante wilder somehow crazy
it's weird they didn't get behind
deontay wilder
he was you're a knockout artist right
but because trace oh the white guy it's
like oh we got rocky he drinks he's a
gypsy
first uh a black american it's [ __ ] up
but in terms of
you know it'd be like it's like luke
donkey he has to learn
he will he's 21 years old
in order to be that transcendent star
you have to be able to you know kick
that [ __ ]
he will over he's 21 years old it's like
dirk never really crossed over though
either with his skill set like he should
have been a bigger deal and he was a
boss
but he was out there when iverson
[ __ ] still though think how good dirk
was
he won mvp but as far i don't think he
wanted to be he played in a shitty march
he was sick yeah but the game is
different though now because
guys on smaller market teams you have
more access to them where
dirk didn't have an instagram account
true he didn't have twitter you know i
mean so he was at dallas maverick i
still think if you go to like okc you're
kind of [ __ ] or like
even utah like it's not it ain't easy it
ain't easy
it ain't easy but it is better to be in
utah
than la and new york right now right now
100 but in general it was just there
it's fantastic right okay what else you
got
oh real quick remember when i pulled up
the ramadan months so we were looking at
i didn't say anything i know so 2021 is
monday april 12
at tuesday may 11th and then 2020 was
april 23rd to may 23rd come to him he
disrespects just making sure
no no i don't know google in front of me
he brought up the wrong ones why i
pulled it up it showed 20 21 i don't
want
to respect out of respect there we go
correct
i see i don't want no problem they don't
bow they don't matter
i'm just doing this worldwide okay okay
uh last one
colin kaepernick is added on as a player
on madden 21.
see this is that more checks here's the
problem
again i don't give a flying [ __ ] do i
put them in the end put in the game
my issue i have with it is let's just
talk it's not a race thing let's talk
about straight up play-making
capabilities
they have him rated at 81 so he's ranked
higher than
15 other starting quarterbacks in the
nfl get the [ __ ] out of here
he's ranked higher than kylo murray he's
ranked higher than ben roethlisberger
get the [ __ ]
kurt cousin like he's ranked higher than
all these guys so if you put him in the
game he hasn't played football in that's
crazy that's what
this is my issue with it it's all but
it's it's it's
and when dick stain wins don't say jack
[ __ ]
agree don't say you guys are going so
far this way
so [ __ ] far with colin kaepernick you
got to realize
yes he's the face of the black lives
matter stuff but y'all realize
four years ago he lost his starting job
to blame gabbard who i don't even think
is playing anymore no
he lost his start he wasn't a good
player and should they
should he have gotten tryouts absolutely
but to put him aboard they try to give
him a trial
they tried to give him a try listen his
life he
his life and he makes more money now his
life and his legacy
will be great it'll be way beyond
football right
as a football player as an athlete you
want to go i don't want to be just an
athlete well you've accomplished that
you took your team to the super bowl
yeah you had an incredible run then then
if i went oh this is what you do they
figured them out and
blaine gabbert beat him out he was on
the bench started doing this
and as it should as a young man life
changes your thoughts change all stuff
like he's more when when lebron says
more than an athlete
colin kaepernick whether you like him or
not is way more than an athlete whether
he should be ranked above kyle or murray
and how crazy is that
insane nuts that's that won't culture
hit madden
it's attic you put him in the game but
the ratings out of control
you just said again it's not a race
thing it's very black and white was he
a good quarterback what's blaine gabba
would he be a good quarterback now four
years out of league
no name one team that would put him over
their starter and why didn't he get a
tryout
from any team not and he didn't get a
[ __ ] try out this summer he could he
should have got a trial there's plenty
of black coaches
they there's no one fights with them
that's it that's it we did it your
clippers
good luck clippers john boyega guys
we once we we begged and plea we begged
and plead a grown man for sneakers we
did
i said i will pay for him because i'm
not a scumbag you don't want to pay
i'll pay i pay for my shoes anyways okay
i i just said virgil with the one
specific kind of sneakers i don't want
to pay
i don't want to go to the store i don't
want to either i don't want to do
anything i just want that one kind
this [ __ ] guy is greedy he wants
everything you do i'm not asking for
that my my request is simple
i'll i'll pay though that's the
difference between us okay i don't think
he's going around with like a
credit card thing like yo honestly he's
got a list i just asked to be on the
[ __ ] list i want to be on the list
too
that's what i'm saying together just
admit it oh yeah but if you have to pick
one of us to be on the list
i would want to be on the list he'll pay
well we love you man don't touch me
want to talk to you well you're the one
with the cough i should be worried about
touching you
you got a horrible cough dude get that
face where you come back will you come
back soon
anytime really whenever you want oh [ __ ]
yeah
let's definitely do it everyone every
other week during the playoffs 100
percent
well the playoffs are ready playhouse
circuit no they're saying the nba
players are gonna be going yo you know
that the
game seven's october 30th oh [ __ ] can
you
isn't that [ __ ] ins just think about
that [ __ ] well think if you're a coach
you can't
see your family talk dave that's
[ __ ] they need to they need that's
nothing they never nice coach
spoke up was like this is [ __ ]
especially because everyone else can
have their family that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense terrible
that that's not cool one of my favorite
images of the bubbles did you see the
of all the wives with all the babies on
the sidelines oh no like there's like
there's like a wife security
did you see the video of uh homeboy the
stud for uh the raptors
seen his kids for the first time yeah it
was cool love it a van
right van fleet oh was it where larry
had one too i had one yeah but there was
a cut of like all that like
they're all like [ __ ] breastfeeding
and [ __ ] with these [ __ ] dudes just
all dime pieces out there
they're all masked up you don't know
what's under those masks who the [ __ ]
everyone looks out of mass though
what happened i said everyone looks hot
in the mat i look good in the mask
yeah look at him so cute all right man
we'll have you back for the playoffs all
right for sure
thank you guys